dans ce bar universitaire quelques fois
par semaine montre que la bière pour le
titre
[Musique]
et des baleines est un adepte de ce
rendez vous loto
une initiative instauré par
l'association étudiante de l'université
du cap-breton
c'est que les étudiants indiens
comédiens sont de plus en plus nombreux
ici
environ 5000 étudiants sont inscrits à
l'université du cap-breton 55 % viennent
de l'étranger de l'inde en particulier
réalisant il ya une dizaine d'années que
les inscriptions étaient sérieusement en
déclin l'établissement a misé sur la
venue d'étudiants étrangers pour assurer
sa survie de nombreuses campagnes de
séduction de l'université ont ciblé des
pays où les jeunes parlent anglais
le nombre d'étudiants à l'université a
donc augmenté en moins d'un an de près
de 45%
ces étudiants paient le double en frais
de scolarité permettant ainsi à
l'université de rester compétitive et en
grande partie les indiens comédie
choisissent le cas breton pour sa
quiétude et aussi pour les programmes
offerts et j'étudie l'administration les
programmes de sciences infirmières de
santé publique ait dégénéré sont aussi
très populaires
[Musique]
et la cantine de l'université offre
maintenant quelques plats traditionnels
[Musique]
ces jeunes trouvent petit à petit leur
place au cap breton
[Musique]
fois par semaine les amis dj prennent
d'assaut ce corridor pour s'entraîner
une façon pour eux de garder le contact
avec leurs origines
la troupe nouvellement formés se produit
même dans des événements de la
communauté arc a mal c est surpris de
voir combien les gens du cap breton les
apprécient ces nouveaux venus se sentent
bien dans la communauté
une île magnifique certes
mais dont l'hiver peut être redoutable
arkema leasing commence à s'y habituer
non pas les hommes
sow une seule chose semble unanimement
leur manquer et j lui ne danse pas mais
lui aussi s'ennuie des plats
traditionnels
tellement qu'il ouvre avec un ami dans
quelques semaines un restaurant indien
soderling à 21 ans les deux jeunes
hommes se pratique à cuisiner à la
maison et font appel aux précieux
conseils de leur mère à venir fixe
diffuseurs comme dj ils sont nombreux à
vouloir rester après leurs études pour
un coin de pays où la mer et la nature
dicte le rythme de vie le rythme
s'accélère
[Musique]
oh